we're starting with a shrimp and  cucumber appetizer we have some sweet  notes from the shrimp some salty notes  from the pickled cucumber and herbaceous  notes from the dill sort of pair with  this we're gonna serve a martini  try to build it up and start a lot of  ice a half part of vermouth two and a  half parts of Bombay Sapphire gin  we're gonna give that a good start now  it's important to star in one direction  the whole time we have our chilled glass  we're in a double strain this into the  glass throw this little lemon zest  the dry flavor of the martini fills out  with the richness of the dill sauce and  then you get a little salty bite from  the shrimp it's a great match serve  these two together and your cocktail  parties off to a great start if you guys  thought this was helpful there's more  tips and tricks on the Jiki channel